[APPLAUSE]
NICHOLAS MEYER: Thank you.
Thanks very much.
Good afternoon.
And thank you for inviting
me to speak here today.
Because I use a computer, I feel
as though I know all of you.
And I'd like to
begin by thanking
each and every one
of you for looking up
all that stuff for me 24/7.
There was not so long
ago an astronomer who
was giving a lecture to
a very full audience,
and he said that the sun
was going to burn out
in 5 billion years,
at which point
an agitated member of the
audience leapt up and said,
what?
What did you say?
Said, I said the sun was going
to burn out in 5 billion years.
And the guy says, whew.
I thought you said
5 million years.
I begin with this story,
A, because I find it funny,
and B, because it touches
on our peculiar relation
to science in this country,
and more particularly,
on our disinclination
to learn or understand
what science tells
us is happening,
has happened, or
will soon happen.
Our ignorance in
this department seems
only equal to Americans'
congenital reluctance
to master any foreign language.
It is scarcely a
secret that we live
in a terrifying world,
a world in which
the viability of planet Earth
itself hangs in the balance.
In these unprecedented
circumstances,
it is hardly surprising
that some people
are inclined to
shoot the messenger,
rather than confront
the message.
The irony is that
most Americans,
while content to profit, buy,
and from amazing scientific
achievements, falling
in love with the latest
must-have gadgetry, display
very little interest
in how such miracles work.
What science causes
airplanes to fly or cancers
to go into remission?
As long as the air
conditioned car goes,
who cares what's under the hood?
More than that, there
are certain segments
of the population
who actively make war
on science,
rejecting information
that frightens them.
They cherry pick the science
they find acceptable or useful,
or seek out reassuring
alternative facts
to suit their emotional
requirements when
objective data upsets them.
I must state at
the outset that I'm
about as far from a
scientist as you can get.
I am still puzzled by gravity.
I must add that I typically read
very little science fiction,
though I adore Jules
Verne and his scientific--
or I should say, unscientific--
but presciently entertaining
rival, HG Wells.
Their differences
are worth noting.
When Verne shot his rocket
to the moon, he did the math
and figured out the
rocket would have
to leave from Cape Canaveral;
that the capsule, when
it returned, would have to be
recovered at sea, et cetera.
By contrast, Wells
simply dreamed up
an anti-gravity
metal called cavorite
and floated his travelers
upward to the lunar surface.
Science fantasy versus
science fiction.
No, I am not a scientist,
just an artist.
As Joseph Conrad wrote, my aim,
above all, is to make you see.
I tell stories, the
purpose of which
is to make people laugh or cry--
in a word, to make you feel.
And if at the end
of what is meant
to be an emotional journey
you wind up thinking
about what you have
felt, so much the better.
But before we go any
further, two caveats.
First, I'd like to
observe that artists
lose all proprietary
authority over their creations
once they're finished.
Artists put messages
in bottles and then
toss them into life's ocean,
hoping that someone will find
and decode what's inside them.
But we won't be around in
every instance of discovery
to say, you're
right, you're wrong.
That's not gum, that's
gun, et cetera--
when and if they do.
The artist's opinion by that
point is just another opinion.
People will make of works
of art what they will.
They always have.
In short, I am not the answer
to a series of equations
at the end of a math book.
I can say what I intended
or attempted to accomplish--
in a word, what I
thought I was doing--
but not what any of it
means to each of you,
much less whether I've
succeeded in my intention.
My second caveat is this.
Like magic tricks
when once explained,
an artist's answers
tend to disappoint.
Art and science,
too, for all I know,
is much more interesting posing
questions than answering them.
As you may gather, this is
going to be a talk about ideas.
There's no visual aids.
Answers may be few, but
perhaps, some of the questions
will hold your attention.
So here goes.
Unlike Oscar Wilde,
who maintained
that all art is
useless, Leo Tolstoy,
the author of my favorite
novel, "War and Peace,"
once stated that
the purpose of art
is to teach us to love life.
No matter how beautiful,
terrible, what we depict,
I think Tolstoy is right.
The bottom line function of art
is to infatuate us with life.
The purpose of art, and
if the purpose of art
is to teach us to love life,
"Star Trek," it seems to me,
totally fills this bill.
Granted, it is more
fiction than science.
But I think many of you,
whom I infer to be devotees,
first became interested
in the universe
by responding to
"Star Trek's" message
about life, its
variety, its value,
and as Spock would
say, its possibilities.
Tolstoy also quibbled
with Shakespeare.
He said, to be not to
be is not the question.
We're here.
The question is, now what?
Isn't that also a
"Star Trek" question?
I happen to be a slow
reader, and slow thinker,
and slow understander.
It may come as a surprise,
but when "Star Trek"
was first telecast shortly
after the Civil War,
I was not among its adherents.
What I saw was a lot of folks
running around cheesy sets
wearing what looked like
Dr. Dentons and a man
with pointy ears.
I never stuck around.
Later, as an undergraduate
at the University of Iowa,
a friend also from New
York, but getting his PhD,
was hooked on the show.
He watched it daily
after he dropped acid.
As I recollect, he did this
for about 54 straight days,
at the end of which
time his wife left him.
There was nothing in this
ritual that encouraged
me to watch the show.
It was many years later
while working in Hollywood
that another friend, an
executive at Paramount
Pictures, encouraged me
to overcome my snobbery
and meet Harve
Bennett, who'd been
assigned to produce the second
"Star Trek" feature film.
Bennett had produced a great
deal of television, including
"The Mod Squad," "Six
Million Dollar Man,"
and the first big time mini
series, "Rich Man, Poor Man."
He had never made
a feature film,
but we got along famously.
He showed me "Star Trek,
The Motion Picture."
Many people are pleased
to knock this film,
but I am not among them.
Director Robert Wise went boldly
where no film had gone before.
If he had made mistakes or
misjudgments along the way,
I would learn from them.
But at the time, "Star
Trek" depicted a world
I didn't understand and
a philosophy to which
I was unable to subscribe.
Other than technology,
I see scant evidence
of the human
condition has changed.
We've added buttons.
We still cannot seem to
get past using our fists,
when we find no other
solution to our disagreements.
It would take me years
and my own involvement
with "Star Trek" to change
my views about the series
and to understand or
start to understand what
it was trying to accomplish.
I did not find
the original film,
as I said, especially
engaging, but Harve
persisted and made
me watch several
of the original
television episodes, which
proved more absorbing
than I had anticipated.
I began to perceive striking
innovations in the show, things
I'd originally failed
to notice while channel
surfing the unprecedented
melting pot,
multinational,
multicultural cast--
the shocking first
televised interracial kiss;
the show's willingness
to confront and grapple
with social issues
that, by setting them
in a sci-fi context,
allowed viewers
to contemplate subject
matter that if set on Earth,
might push so many bias
buttons, that shackled
by our prejudices, we
might never consider
such topics objectively.
The best science
fiction, it seems to me,
whether set in the past,
future, or outer space,
seems always to reflect the
human condition of the time
in which it was created.
Watching these episodes also
put me pleasantly in mind
of something I liked,
but it took me a while--
it always takes me a while--
to tease out what it was--
a series of novels
by CS Forester, who
also wrote "The African Queen"
about an officer in the Royal
Navy during the Napoleonic Wars,
one Captain Horatio Hornblower.
Hornblower's adventures
and exploits,
which always included
a girl in every port,
had fed my pre-adolescent
fantasy life.
And I now recognized
with an agreeable shock
that Captain Kirk was
Hornblower in outer space.
Later, when I discussed
this with Bill Shatner,
he became excited
and said, that's
exactly what Roddenberry said.
Now I was starting
to become stoked
about the idea of
directing a Hornblower
movie with spaceships.
But even after all this time, an
involvement with three feature
films-- that would
be 2, 4, and 6,
for those of you
who keep score--
I still hadn't gleaned all that
"Star Trek" had to teach me.
It may seem strange
how long it took
me to understand
that while Hornblower
might be a way into Star
Trek, it wasn't all there was.
Adding submarines
or battleships might
have enabled me to create
"Star Trek" movies,
but it was only after
the fact that I finally
began to grasp how essential
the idea of the show was
and what made it precious
to so many people.
And in "Star Trek 6,"
Spock says that logic
is the beginning of
wisdom, but not the end.
Hornblower might be
the beginning of a way
to think about "Star Trek," but
it certainly was not the end.
Predicting the future,
whether in real life
or what we term science
fiction, is a tricky business.
And most prognosticators,
professional and amateur,
get the future wrong.
True.
"Star Trek" got
cell phones right.
But who could have
foreseen Donald Trump?
Science fiction always
winds up depicting
the time in which it was
made, rather than the time
in which it is supposedly set.
But one thing "Star Trek"
does that finally resonated
with me was its optimism.
Its implicit thesis
that problems
were capable of solutions--
they may not always be the
simplest or most gratifying
solutions, but
again, quoting Spock,
there are always possibilities.
Mankind has frequently
been confronted
by seemingly insoluble problems
that were then somehow solved.
You people must know all
about solving problems.
To take a random instance, by
the turn of the 20th century,
New York City, clogged
with horse drawn vehicles,
was literally drowning in shit.
The pollution threatened
the safety and health
of the great metropolis.
And then mirabile dictu,
along came the automobile.
And in short order, the
horse manure problem
went away, granted,
to be replaced by car
exhaust and engine noise.
But with recent advances
in electric cars,
some of which I've
lately sampled
in the neighborhood, maybe
the exhaust problem and even
the drunk driver
problem will go away.
Similarly, bubonic
plague periodically
decimated huge
swaths of humanity.
And then came the
miracle of vaccination.
And diseases, including
smallpox, tuberculosis,
and polio, were, for all intents
and purposes, eradicated.
People who were so frightened by
the prospect of climate change
that they cannot concede
its reality would do well
to immerse themselves in "Star
Trek," which can, like Tolstoy,
teach us to love life, believing
that just as science shows us
difficulties, science, coupled
with men and women of goodwill,
can uncover solutions.
So, too, "Star Trek's"
science of optimism
can fill us with plausible
hope that human beings, working
together, can surmount seemingly
intractable difficulties.
As I began by observing, we
live in a terrifying world,
I confess, a world whose
very survival seems to be
hanging by a fraying thread.
No wonder we spend so much
time amusing ourselves
to death in trivial pursuits,
or insubstantial escapism video
games, or movies
featuring men in Spandex--
so-called superheroes,
saints for a secular society
where Mickey Mouse and Superman
head the pantheon of gods.
Because mere heroes are
no longer sufficient.
What I have more recently
come to understand
is that "Star Trek," on a
more sophisticated level
than Batman, for
example, provides
what is perhaps a more plausible
optimism than Superman.
It attempts to show a world not
where Superman can rescue us,
but where humankind
can improve, where
the definition of
progress isn't that just
because we can do
something, it doesn't
follow that we must do it.
Technology must not become
the tail wagging the dog.
It does not follow that
because we can blow ourselves
to smithereens, we must blow
ourselves to smithereens.
That men and women are
capable of learning
from past mistakes--
in a word, capable of evolving--
dangerous word with connotations
to another word, evolution.
But there, we've swallowed it.
"Star Trek" arguably
doesn't promise superpowers.
But it does hold
out the possibility
of evolved change, a belief
that human beings may never
be perfect, but that striving
for perfection, trying
in the spirit of intelligent
and humane query,
is a legitimate
and desirable goal.
In addition to Tolstoy's
dictum that the purpose of art
is to teach us to
love life, "Star Trek"
has taught me something else--
that art has the power to
change how we see and experience
the world.
It is no accident that
most original members
of NASA and JPL got their
start and inspiration watching
that crude television series.
The sun, remember, will
extinguish itself in 5 billion,
not 5 million years.
"Star Trek" urges care
in carefully carving out
our human destinies.
We could do worse
than to consult
the science of optimism.
Thank you, and I'm happy
to answer questions.
[APPLAUSE]
If there are no more questions.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm [INAUDIBLE].
Thanks for being here today.
There's--
NICHOLAS MEYER: No charge.
AUDIENCE: Kind of non-written
rule among "Star Trek"
fans that even numbered
movies in the franchise,
the original one--
NICHOLAS MEYER: Oh, shucks.
AUDIENCE: The best ones.
How do you react to that?
And how do you see the odd
numbered movies in the series?
NICHOLAS MEYER:
Well, first of all,
you're obviously very
discerning and completely right.
I don't know what it
is about those even
numbered "Star Treks" that
is worth our attention,
or devotion, or adoration.
I'm just picking random words.
I'm not about to pick apart
anybody else's movies.
I feel that I was very lucky.
Movies are like souffles.
They either rise, or they don't.
And the fact that
mine rose is like--
my mother is very happy.
What can I tell you?
I don't know what else to--
I think it's good that
people like the even
numbered ones, so.
Remember, I said
artists aren't the best
judges of their own work.
So it's just like whatever I
say is just another opinion.
AUDIENCE: Mr. Meyer, thank
you so much for being here.
I have a question about
the movie, "The Day After."
For those who don't
know what it is,
it's a TV movie that
scared the bejesus out
of most of North America.
It was all about
nuclear annihilation
during the Cold War.
So I'm just curious
if you can tell us
how that project came about
and maybe your reaction
to the country's
reaction to that movie.
NICHOLAS MEYER: This
is an enormous topic.
For those of you
who do not know,
"The Day After" is
the most watched movie
ever made for television.
I didn't write it.
I directed it.
It came out in 1983.
It was watched by 100
million people in one night.
"The New York Post" called me a
traitor on its editorial page.
There are lots of stories
about "The Day After."
And I can tell you a little bit
about how I became involved,
and then I'll tell
you my favorite story,
which is not so much about me.
I was the fourth director
that ABC of television
offered to do this movie.
The thing about nuclear war
is that the nuclear dilemma,
the ability of the human
race to extinguish itself,
is a relatively recent
development, 1945.
At the same time, there is
something so terrifying,
that most of us prepare not to--
we don't think about it.
We've learned to
kind of dial it out.
And we go about
our business with
this Damoclean nuclear sword
hanging over our necks,
and we sort of pretend
that it isn't there.
And we may tell ourselves
that we're doing OK.
But you've no idea
how many close calls
or how many bombs have been
dropped that, by the way,
didn't go off, including
two once on North Carolina.
So we're hanging
by a thread here.
I didn't want to have anything
to do with this either.
I was having a good time.
I was making "Star Trek"
movies and meeting girls.
It was all fine.
But I was also being
psychoanalyzed at the time.
And my shrink never spoke.
You have to understand how
psychoanalysis works, is
that you're doing
the heavy lifting.
You go in there, and you say
whatever comes into your head.
And at the end of it, he
plays it back for you,
but slightly rearranged.
But he's not volunteering.
He's not a guru.
But in this case,
he opened his mouth.
As I'm lying there
on the couch, trying
to figure a way not to
do this, and he said,
well, I guess this is where we
find out who you really are.
And I realized at that point
that I had no choice, because I
have to shave in the morning.
And that's tricky if you
don't look at yourself.
And I actually corralled
a lot of people
into the movie with
that damn line.
I told my cinematographer
from "Star Trek 2,"
we're going to do
this nuclear thing.
He goes, aw, no, no, no, no.
Don't.
Come on.
And I said, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
Let me get this straight.
The one time this
town is going to allow
you to put your work in the
service of your beliefs,
you're going to pass and
bitch at dinner parties?
I think this is where we
find out who you really are.
So that's how I got
into making the movie.
And there's a million details.
There are books
about this movie.
There are PhD theses, and
there are crazy stories.
There was a general
on Castro's staff
who later said that the
Cuban Missile Crisis had not
been real to him, until
he had seen the movie.
Can you imagine?
And the morning after
the movie was on TV--
and I sat and watched it.
And I thought, who
in their right mind
would sit through this?
It's available on Blu-ray,
by the way, if you wanted to.
I don't think I'm
selling it very well.
Anyway, I was mildly
astounded, to put it mildly,
that 100 million
people had watched it,
and the phones were ringing
off the hook the next morning.
I guess all that publicity
from people running up and down
protesting the movie,
but it had scared up
a lot of-- nothing like being
banned in Boston to sell books.
At which point, the media, as
we call them, ever helpful,
ran around with their
microphone, saying,
did this movie change your mind
about nuclear war, yea or nay?
And then came, rather gleefully,
I thought, running back to me
and saying, according to
our morning after survey,
your movie didn't
change anybody's minds
about nuclear war
one way or the other.
What do you have to say?
And I said, well, number
one, I don't think people
change their minds overnight.
Number two, I don't think they'd
tell you if their minds were
changed by a TV movie.
Number three, I'm not sure
people know what they really
think anyway.
If you say, do you believe
in God or you ask a question,
people will tell you,
give you an answer.
But maybe until there's
a gun put to their head,
you don't really know
what they really think.
But there was one
person whose mind was
changed by the movie very fast.
And he happened to be the
President of the United
States, Ronald Reagan.
There is a lot of
evidence, including
Reagan's own memoir, for the
effect that the movie had.
But the end result was
that he flew to Reykjavik,
met with Gorbachev,
whom he had previously
called the architect of the
evil empire or something,
and they signed the Intermediate
Range Nuclear Weapons
Treaty, the Missile Treaty.
And he had come
to power believing
in a winnable nuclear war.
And he changed his mind.
And not only does his
own memoir say this,
but I became friends with
his in-house biographer,
a rather interesting man
named Edmund Morris, who
won the Pulitzer
Prize for his book,
"The Rise of
Theodore Roosevelt."
And I got to know Morris.
And Morris said he'd lived
in the house for three years
while he was writing this book.
He said the only time he
saw Ronald Reagan freak out
was after the movie.
There's lots more
stories about it,
but it's probably
to date, until I
got to speak to you guys, the
most worthwhile thing I ever
got to do with my life.
AUDIENCE: Mr. Meyer,
thanks for joining us.
I want to ask you
about the theme
that you were speaking
about in terms of optimism,
regarding optimism
in science fiction.
I'm curious, more specifically--
you mentioned a couple of
times about science fiction
as reflecting the state
of society and kind
of the concerns
that preoccupations
of contemporary folks.
So I'm curious, what do you
see as kind of circumstances
that will give rise to kind
of different forms of science
fiction?
And I guess, what
I'm referring to,
in particular, is
like, often, we see--
and this is something that
other folks, like film
critics, cultural
critics, have seen--
is that science
fiction, especially
over the past couple of
decades, it's very much been
in the sort of cyberpunk mode.
It's like this really kind
of dystopian depictions
of capitalism, maybe going back
to "Blade Runner," maybe going
back beyond, and
how, for some people,
that's a kind of-- or
the origins of that
is a kind of critique of
neoliberal capitalism.
I'm curious if you
kind of share that.
And then what do you
think might give rise
to sort of new inspirations
for science fiction
into the future?
Or do you have
thoughts about what
might sort of result
in a more optimistic
or the return of a
more optimistic vision,
like what you were
referring to in "Star Trek?"
NICHOLAS MEYER:
Well, again, this
is just one person's
extremely uninformed opinion,
but I look at the
world, at the moment,
and I see what I consider to
be some very ominous trends.
I see a very divisive
and destructive leader
in this country.
I see the sort of
disappointment and failure
of democracies around
the world, whether we're
talking about India under Modi
or various European countries
that are all drifting right.
And I find it very chilling
and very frightening.
But I think that,
speaking for myself
and my own creative
ideas, I would
take whatever science fiction
I'm working on and try--
again, I use the
word plausibly--
to construct scenarios that are
believably optimistic out of--
take the horse shit image
that looks really bad.
And things have looked
really bad before.
They've looked bad politically.
They've looked bad in the
midst of the bubonic plague.
They have looked bad before.
When you read certain
histories of certain times--
if you read about
Andrew Johnson,
who will give the incumbent a
run for his money as the worst
president, when you look at some
terrible political campaigns
that have been run in
times before this--
and Thomas Jefferson was
one of the worst offenders
when he ran against John Adams.
And he hired people to write
the most awful, awful things,
untrue.
And Adams was the first
president, the only president,
not to attend the inauguration
of his successor--
even though he later
patched up everything
with Thomas Jefferson.
I don't know if you
know this story,
but they never saw
each other again.
They had collaborated on the
Declaration of Independence,
and Adams went up to
Braintree, Massachusetts
after his presidency.
Jefferson retreated
to Monticello.
They never saw each other again.
But they had a mutual
friend, Dr. Benjamin Rush,
who said to John
Adams, this is a shame.
You guys started a country.
You're really not going to
ever say anything to him?
He's got a birthday coming up.
Why don't you send him a card?
And Adam said, well,
supposing he doesn't answer.
And Rush said, John,
send them a card.
So he sends him a
letter, happy birthday.
And he was absolutely
delighted, stunned.
After all this acrimony,
and time, and distance,
got an instant reply.
And thus begins the most
famous correspondence
in American letters,
that for the last 10, 12
years of their lives, these
guys write about everything.
They write about the weather.
They write about their children.
They write about their farms.
They write about-- but they're
also writing about the country,
and about themselves, and
before the bar of history.
And if that isn't overcoming
something, I don't know what.
But they did, better yet,
they died on the same day.
What day would that be?
AUDIENCE: July 4.
NICHOLAS MEYER: You bet.
July 4, 50 years to
the day after they
signed the Declaration,
after they wrote it.
And John Adams' last words were,
Thomas Jefferson still lives.
So things are possible.
And it isn't just
science fiction
that reflects the time
in which it was created.
All art reflects the time
Mozart doesn't just
sound like Mozart.
He sounds like late 18th
century middle European music.
Renoir doesn't just
look like Renoir.
He looks like 19th century
French Impressionism.
You can identify.
If I show you four movies
that are set in 1776,
and one was made in 1906,
and one is made in 1936,
and one is made in 1996, and
the other one is made in 2006,
you will know
within five minutes,
most within five years,
when those works of art
were created.
Either because of the way
people look, the way they sound,
what comes out of their mouths,
how long their eyelashes are,
what their hairstyle is, or
what their political ideology
is invested in the
content of the film.
So science fiction is not alone.
And speaking for myself,
I just tell stories,
and I've never
cared whether it was
a future story or a past story,
comical, tragical, tragical,
historical, it doesn't matter.
I just want it to
be a good story.
And somebody said, well,
what's your definition
of a good story?
My definition of a good story
is that after you've heard it,
you understand why I
wanted to tell it to you.
And I wanted to teach
you to love life.
AUDIENCE: Question
from the Dory here,
from Bradley in San Francisco--
he said my project at Google
is named Tricorder, after
the "Star Trek" device.
What is your favorite instance
of a product's technology
or fashion that you think
was inspired by "Star Trek?"
NICHOLAS MEYER: Oh, gosh.
This calls for a
level of expertise
that I think is
beyond my pay grade.
That phone thing, I think, is
the most remarkable instance
of science fiction, actually
prognosticating, predicting
something that was coming.
You could argue that the Dick
Tracy two-way wrist watch
was sort of in the same vein.
But the cell phone seems to
bear a remarkable resemblance.
Of course, they no longer
need the fliptop of it.
But otherwise, it
was pretty cool.
It's a scary device.
That phone is like
smarter than me, which
may not be saying that much.
But it may be smarter
than a lot of you, too.
AUDIENCE: So you talked a little
bit about how, as an artist,
you're trying to say things.
So I was wondering
if you could just
mention a few maybe particular
things that you were trying
to say, or details that
you had a hand in or wanted
to do a particular way in some
of those "Star Trek" movies?
NICHOLAS MEYER: Well,
again, it looks almost
like you're asking for answers
at the back of the book, which
I'm not--
AUDIENCE: I was asking
what your intent--
NICHOLAS MEYER:
My intention was--
AUDIENCE: Your intention,
not for what you did,
what your intention--
NICHOLAS MEYER: I think
the best villains in movies
are villains that
you can agree with.
When you talk about Khan
in my movie, for example,
he's got a point.
Admiral Kirk never bothered
to check on our progress.
When you look at Richard III,
there are problems there.
You can understand why this
is an angry, bitter man.
And it doesn't always have to
be something that's sort of self
evident in that way.
I was once working on
a James Bond movie.
And I was told before I
got on the plane to London,
we have two questions.
What does the villain want?
And parenthetically,
remember, he's already
wanted the gold in Fort
Knox, the atom bombs,
the guided missiles,
control of outer space,
control of the water way.
And number two, keep it simple.
Well, it's a long plane ride.
And I'm sure you
all know, you have
smart days and stupid days, days
when you come home and you go,
oh, oh.
And then there are days
when you go, hello, this is
why they pay you the big bucks.
So I said--
I'm meeting in a room.
There was like 30 people
sitting in the room.
And I said, OK, it seems to
me when you look at James Bond
movies that they have
something of the formality
of an English sonnet.
It's a highly structured thing,
or a haiku, or something.
It starts with the amazing
opening stunt, followed
by colorful title credits, theme
song, followed by James Bond
goes to see M and
banters with Moneypenny.
Gets assignment from
M, and then there's
action sequence, action
sequence, action sequence,
until he meets Mr. Big,
who says, no, Mr. Bond.
It's not about the money.
It's about fill in the blank.
And so I thought, imagine
all this has happened.
And Bond is now
in Mr. Big's lair.
And in this version of
events, Mr. Big says,
Mr. Bond, everything that's
happened to you up till now
has been a kind of test.
I just wanted to see if
you were the man for me.
And I think you may just be.
I think when you get
to know me, that you'll
find out that fundamentally,
I'm a people person.
There's too many of them.
Even lemmings.
Even lemmings, Mr. Bond.
And he pushes a button,
and oh, look, there I am.
Have I been there
the whole time?
Was I doing the same thing
back there that I was?
Then why are you looking--
anyway.
He pushes the buttons,
and all these monitors
come up of overpopulation--
traffic jams in Los Angeles,
starving people in Ethiopia,
whatever.
Even lemmings, Mr.
Bond, know what
to do when they
grow too numerous.
I am willing to bite
the bullet on a question
that no politician
will even touch.
Will you help me, 007?
That's some kind of
license, isn't it?
How much game are you allowed
to bag without license?
Will you help me
save planet Earth?
And there's dead
silence in this room.
Here's a villain.
He was absolutely right.
And his idea was to start a
war between India and China,
the two most populous nations.
And the next day, I came back,
and it was off the table.
Too serious.
But I had come up with--
I had fulfilled the assignment.
It was simple.
It hadn't been done before.
And my dictum, if you can
agree with the villain,
then the hero really
has to be on his mettle.
Bond really has to be good.
You know what I said.
Yeah, and Bond
says, you're right.
I will help you.
And I said, don't worry.
The smart people in the
audience know he's not really
going to help him.
And the stupid people
will be surprised
when he doesn't help
him, so you can't lose.
AUDIENCE: And that became
the "Infinity War."
NICHOLAS MEYER: Oh, did it?
I didn't see it.
Anyway.
I see little movies.
There's a movie called
"The Hummingbird Project"
that I saw.
Did anybody see this movie?
About trying to build a high
speed fiber optic network
between Kansas and
Wall Street to beat
the amount of information
by a millimeter
of a second in order--
that was interesting to me.
I like to see
movies about people
trying to figure out shit.
But if it gets too
noisy and too loud,
I kind of hunker down
and find more popcorn.
AUDIENCE: All right, we have
another question on the Dory.
This one's from
Hannah in San Bruno.
This one says your
journey as a writer
started with the 7% solution.
How did you decide
to write that,
and what made you shift
to writing screenplays?
NICHOLAS MEYER: OK, long story.
And by the way, if you
guys get up and leave,
I can take a hint.
In the first place,
before I finish this,
I should say that I have another
Sherlock Holmes book coming out
in October, called "The
Adventure of the Peculiar
Protocols," which you
can preorder, by the way,
on Amazon.
I didn't start out
wanting to be--
I wanted to make movies.
I fell in love with movies
at a very early age.
And that's what I wanted to do.
So books is kind of an
afterthought in the sideline.
My father was a psychoanalyst,
and I would go to school,
and people would say, oh,
your old man's a shrink.
Is he a Freudian?
And I didn't know.
So I said, Papa,
are you a Freudian?
And he said, oh, that's
kind of a silly question.
And I said, why?
Why is it a silly question?
And he said, because it's
no more possible to discuss
the beginnings or the
history of psychoanalysis
and not start with Freud.
It's like saying we're
going to discuss the history
of the discovery of America.
And we're not going to talk
about Columbus or the Vikings.
But to suppose that nothing
has happened since the Vikings
is to be pretty rigid,
pretty doctrinaire.
When a patient comes to see
me, I listen to what they say.
I listen to how they say it.
I'm especially curious as
to what they do not say.
I'm looking to see if they're
on time, what kind of clothes
they're wearing, what
their body language is.
I am in short searching
for clues from them
as to why they are not happy.
And against this, I
apply a background
of some clinical experience.
And I said-- I'm like 13
years old or something--
it sounds like detective
work, what you do.
And he said, it is like
detective work, in a way.
And I suddenly realized
who my father had always
reminded me of.
Because I was reading all
the Sherlock Holmes books,
all the Arthur
Conan Doyle books.
And I thought, gosh, I
wonder how much Arthur Conan
Doyle knew about the
writing of Sigmund Freud.
And the first thing I learned
is that they're both doctors.
They both died in the same
city within nine years
of each other.
Holmes is a cocaine addict,
and so was, for a time, Freud.
And these coincidences
and even more than that,
because Freud's first
exposure to cocaine
had been with the paper
he wrote with two eye
doctors, Konigstein and
Curler, on the uses of cocaine
as an anesthetic
during eye surgery.
Conan Doyle had
studied ophthalmology
for six months in Vienna.
And out of all this,
over many years--
because I tell you, I'm
a very slow thinker.
So I started this
thought when I was 13,
but the book didn't
come out till I was 28.
And no one I knew was interested
in Sherlock Holmes, except me.
So I just waited.
The Writers Guild
went on strike.
I was writing movies
and television movies.
But I wasn't allowed to.
And my friends said, so now
you can write that book you've
always been talking about.
I never dreamed
that it was going
to become the number
one best selling
novel of the United States.
That was a surprise.
So since I'm thinking
we're out of hands,
I guess I'll let you guys go
back to fixing the future.
And please hurry up.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]